[Musique]
nadia et bonjour bonjour et bienvenue
dans ce numéro du café politique à les y
installer vous merci de m'avoir invité
on va revenir sur votre parcours
politique évidemment sur votre parcours
personnel ce qui vous a amené à la
politique vous êtes depuis juin dernier
député de la 11e circonscription des
yvelines élu de la république en marche
vous êtes apparu dans le paysage
politique dans la foulée de la campagne
présidentielle et l'élection de
d'emmanuel macron dites nous quel était
avant votre votre rapport à la politique
est ce que vous étiez une simple
citoyenne qui allaient voter les jours
d'élections alors vous étiez déjà
particulièrement intéressé par par
l'actualité politique
c'est effectivement une citoyenne mais
j'étais également une citoyenne
particulièrement intéressé par la
politique c'est un sujet qui m'a
toujours passionné même si effectivement
je n'ai jamais eu d'engagement politique
auparavant j'étais une de ses citoyennes
qui étaient déçus par la politique dont
qui c'est qui s'exerçait depuis
plusieurs années maintenant et le déclic
du cou qui vous a poussé à vous engager
concrètement c'est le discours d'
emmanuel macron qui maquille mac a
poussé à m'engager en fait c'est une
personnalité politique que je suivais
alors qu'il était encore ministre un
espoir de l'économie puisque mon
activité professionnelle nous inciter
effectivement à suivre l'actualité
économique et donc c'est un discours
pour moi qui résonnait différemment et
une vision déjà différente quand il
était ministre et je me suis dit je
pense qu'il s'engagera et qu'il ira plus
loin
et s'il s'il se présente aux élections
présidentielles et ben moi aussi j'y
vais parce que parce que c'est un
discours qui sonne bien et il a appelé
justement la société civile à s'engager
à aller plus loin parce qu'il avait
besoin de renouveler les visages mais
surtout les méthodes et donc j'y suis
allé dans plusieurs articles de presse
qui vous ont été consacrés à la suite de
votre élection en juin 2017
on a pu lire et il y avait inscrit que
vous votiez à gauche avant est ce que
c'est vrai est ce que vous vous mettiez
notamment pour le parti socialiste
plutôt avant il ya beaucoup de gens du
parti socialiste qui ont rejoint en
marche est ce que c'était votre cas vous
aussi alors je suis effectivement
quelqu'un de dont le l'action sociale
est et pour moi importante et
et j'ai voté effectivement à gauche je
vous avouerai aussi que j'ai déjà pour
des élections locales voter à droite
vous connais très bien finalement au
prototype on va dire en marche droite
gauche le prototype dans le marché ce
qui sait ce qui constitue l'adn dans
marche et je pense qu'on a dépassé ce
clivage droite gauche
on est dans une optique collégiale de
rassemblement de tout tout horizon
politique
à partir du moment où on partage la même
vision les mêmes idées et surtout le
projet de notre président de la
république dès lors qu'on y adhère
on est les bienvenus à la république en
marche vous avez vous avez grandi à
trappes donc au coeur de cette 11e
circonscription des yvelines trappe qui
a été longtemps une ville communiste qui
est maintenant socialiste qu'elle était
aussi le rapport à la politique quand
vous étiez plus jeune au sein de la
famille est ce que c'était un sujet la
politique ou alors vous avez une famille
qui était plutôt apolitiques ou une
famille engagée politiquement est-ce
qu'on parlait de politique à table par
exemple
alors ma famille n'était pas engagé
politiquement mais on parlait énormément
politique mon défunt père adoré ça donc
les les soirées à table et ai été assez
animé il suivait la politique étrangère
il suivait la politique européenne et la
politique nationale et c'est un sujet
effectivement qu'on a qu'on a beaucoup
beaucoup abordé à table dans les
réunions de famille j'ai aussi des
oncles qui sont alors qu'ils qui sont
également très intéressés par la
politique et donc c'est un sujet
effectivement de discussions et je vous
laisse imaginer aujourd'hui la fierté
peut-être que ça que ça engendre
oui oui ma famille est très fière mes
amis aussi sont très fiers de beaux
parcours et j'en suis fier également
aussi maintenant c'est pas tout d'être
fier je pense qu'il faut être humble et
life où il faut être
on va travailler pour le pour ce
territoire si particulier très très
convoité cette 11e circonscription on se
rappelle il y avait tout de même benoît
hamon candidat ps à la présidentielle
ancien député député sortant le maire
d'elancourt aussi jean michel fourgous
ancien député de cette 11e
circonscription et une campagne un peu
on va dire assez assez offensive de ses
opposants politiques qui vous ont qui
vous ont reproché de ne pas être connues
de ne pas connaître le terrain les
problèmes du territoire est ce que tout
ça c'est un faux procès selon vous alors
est-ce que vous reconnaissez vous ont
reproché aussi de surfer énormément sur
cette vague
emmanuel macron est ce que c'est un faux
procès selon vo ou alors vous
reconnaissez que sans l'élection
emmanuel macron ne serais probablement
pas là aujourd'hui c'est une question à
laquelle malheureusement pour on pourra
pas apporter d'affirmations très juste
parce que
sait on par beaucoup sur des
suppositions en tout cas il ya une chose
qui est certaine c'est que j'ai été face
à notamment deux principaux candidats
c'était quand même une campagne
exactement dont l'un pour le dernier
donc monsieur benoît hamon qui est qu'à
exercer cinq ans ici on lui a beaucoup
reproché son absence sur le territoire
après son élection alors que c'était une
personnalité tout de même et nationale
éducation nationale donc et par là par
ses engagements également être à
l'échelle nationale il était extrêmement
connu mais dont les retombées finalement
sur la 11e circonscription n'était que
très peu visible voire inexistantes
ensuite on avait un second candidat jean
michel fourgous qui lui a eu trois
mandats surpasser sur la circonscription
la 11e et on a vu pendant son mandat et
même le bilan après après après ses
trois mandats où finalement on a observé
qu'une un accroissement des inégalités
entre dans les océans des territoires et
finalement une république qui pendant
toutes ces années là a commencé à
reculer dans certains quartiers de la
11e circonscription
donc il ya eu énormément de déception de
la part de nos concitoyens et vous
l'avez dit c'est une circonscription qui
est très prisé parce que wired eux aussi
médiatiquement très regardée mais
médiatiquement une parce qu'elle est
extrêmement intéressante elle
extrêmement intéressante par les
difficultés qu'elles rencontrent
il y en a beaucoup mais elle également
extrêmement intéressante par les
richesses le dpe me levais ici avant est
contenu par exemple exactement
montigny-le-bretonneux mais on parle
aussi de la zone industrielle de trappes
de la zone d'activités de trappes à bois
d'arcy également une grande zone
d'activités donc c'est c'est une zone
très très dynamique d'un point de vue
économique mais dont les retombées sur
la population et notamment sur les
populations les plus fragiles ils vont
un vrai sujet à se faire sans qui a du
mal à se faire sentir avec
l'accroissement du taux de chômage qu'on
a observé ces de ces cinq dernières
années qui est qui qui qui aujourd'hui
est extrêmement important donc
vraiment circonscription extrêmement
intéressante où il ya beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup à faire
très rapidement sur sur vos rapports
avec avec jean michel fourgous qui est
tout même le président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines donc vous êtes
souvent amenés à le côtoyer
on a vu dans la presse que sa mort
notamment lors des voeux de
l'agglomération qui a vu quelques
quelques tensions est ce que vous
arrivez tout de même à travailler
sereinement avec jean michel fourgous
qui est le président de saint quentin en
yvelines le nouveau président j'aimerais
pouvoir travailler sereinement avec lisa
pas le chaos mais très honnêtement non
ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui parce qu'à partir
du moment où on rentre dans une espèce
de communication mensongère et des infos
ou de la désinformation ça me pose
vraiment un problème parce que je pense
que on doit passer au delà de nos
séparations politique de nos deux noms
de nos divergences d'opinion et agir
ensemble pour le territoire et je crois
qu'il n'est pas dans cette optique là il
n'est pas dans tout cas dans la même
démarche qui est la mienne j'ai je
travaille énormément avec l'autre les
autres maires notamment parce qu'il faut
pas oublier qu'il est également maire
d'elancourt je travaille beaucoup avec
les autres maires des communes des
autres des six autres communes et je
n'arrive pas à travailler avec lui donc
c'est qu'il ya un vrai pro des habitants
vont en pâtir selon vous sur le long
terme seraient bloqués des réseaux
nettement j'espère pas je ne l'espère
pas de tout mon coeur parce que ils
n'ont pas à pâtir de ces divergences
politiques
donc j'ai fait le premier pas pour
demander un rendez vous avec lui ou dans
lequel on va s'entretenir vraiment tous
les deux et se mettre d'accord sur une
ligne de conduite
et si je vois que la ligne de conduite
ne tient pas eh bien ce n'est pas grave
j'avancerai sans lui c'est cesser c'est
aussi clair que ça je ne peux pas être
plus clair
on va parler un petit peu de politiques
nationales puisque au sein de
l'assemblée nationale vous êtes
vous êtes membre de la commission des
finances vous êtes une ancienne
banquière donc la logique est respectée
je veux dire qu'est ce que vous répondez
à aux opposants politiques qui disent
qu'ils aient emmanuel macron c'est le
président des riches
vous êtes sur un territoire vous le
disiez où il ya beaucoup de difficultés
à trappes à la verrière notamment est ce
qu on vous ressort aussi parfois cet
argument est ce que vous l'entendez et
que répondez vous à cet argument là moi
je dis que c'est un faux débat et c'est
un faux procès président des riches ont
le haut c'est une c'est une c'est un nom
qu'on lui a donné un titre qui a été
donné par l'examen au sénat par la
gauche
exactement donc c'est un c'est un surnom
qui a été donné par l'opposition et donc
à partir de là je n'ai pas à commenter
ce ce terme là qui vont parisien pas la
roue territoire sur le terrain on vous
en parle quand celui mamba ont mis qu'on
me demande d'expliquer pourquoi la
hausse de la csg sur le retraité qui
n'ont pas de compensation par rapport à
la taxe d'habitation
on me demande de d'expliquer quelle est
notre action en matière de politique de
la ville on demande d'expliquer vraiment
nos actions très concrètes sur le
terrain beaucoup comprennent que pour
pour redynamiser un petit peu notre
économie ça passe par une bonne santé de
nos entreprises eh bien il faut alléger
la fiscalité pour effectivement investir
dans l'est dans l'économie il faut
alléger la fiscalité sur le capital tout
ça part d'une logique très clair et une
ligne de conduite qui était connu à
l'avancé et pour autant qui a permis à
notre président des tribus je voulais
vous parler aussi de votre engagement
pour les droits des femmes c'est un
sujet qui vous intéresse énormément
aujourd'hui il ya quelqu'un qui porte ce
message en français c'est marlène
schiappa l'ats la secrétaire d'état
comment vous regardez son parcours
politique certes beaucoup la critique
d'autres beaucoup jugent son action très
très positif pour les droits des femmes
est ce que vous vous suivez plus
attentivement son parcours à l est ce
que c'est un peu être un modèle pour
vous aussi politique marlène schiappa
déjà quand on parle de marlène schiappa
on parle d'une personne qui est
extrêmement engagée sur le sujet elle le
porte avec conviction parce qu'elle le
porte avec son coeur et sa à partir du
moment où on parle avec son coeur mois
chez moi ça suscite l'admiration
parce qu'on n'est pas justement dans du
discours préfabriqué on n'est pas dans
une vision qui serait
celle qu'on aimerait
avoir ou c'est vraiment quelque chose de
pas dans de la politique pure et dure
elle n'est pas dans la politique
politicienne elle dit ce qu'elle pense
elle a raison de dire ce qu'elle pense
parfois effectivement il faut les
dérapages qu'on peut avoir parce que
justement nous n'avons pas cette
maîtrise politique
condé des treize anciens politiciens
mais moi je dis à la limite tant mieux
parce que ça veut vraiment dire qu'on
est engagée cons et qu'on n'est pas dans
le calcul et ça pour moi c'est ça mérite
le respect dernière question d'actualité
pour conclure cette émission il ya un
livre qui a fait récemment la une de
l'actualité qui a fait aussi parfois
polémique c'est la communauté ce livre
qui retrace un peu l'histoire de ces
dernières décennies de trappes la ville
qui fait partie de votre circonscription
écrit par raphaëlle bacqué ariane chemin
de journalistes du monde
est ce que vous l'avez lu déjà en tant
que député de la circonscription et
qu'est ce que vous en avez pensé selon
vous est-ce que ça retrace la ville que
vous connaissez l'histoire de la ville
que vous connaissez vous alors j'ai lu
effectivement le livre d'ariel chemin et
de raphaëlle bacqué qui pour moi
mais l'accent sur vraiment d'eux qu'il
ya deux aspects on montre effectivement
la solidarité qui existe dans la ville
de trappes tous ces beaux aspects tout
vraiment ce qui fait ce qui fait la
richesse de cette wilaya aussi qu'ils
sont fait connaître dans le monde entier
presque au delà au delà même de ses
stars moi je pense que c'est une âme
qu'on est en train de décrire et l'âme
de trappes elles existent vous savez moi
j'ai quitté trappe à 27 ans j'ai habité
dix ans à paris survenue m'installer
dans les yvelines
mais trappe c'est ma ville de coeur je
ne les jamais quitté toute ma vie est
construite autour de cette ville et dans
cette ville donc ça montre effectivement
l'attachement et de l'amour qu'on peut
avoir pour la ville et à côté de ça sa
trace aussi enfin le la réalité qu'on
rencontre aujourd'hui et les difficultés
qui seront qui se sont créées ces
dernières années où ces dernières
décennies à trappes et donc pour moi
c'est un livre qui est très équilibré
qu'à trouver le bon équilibre entre
montrer ce qui est beau ce qui fait ce
qui fait notre attachement à la ville de
trappes et à côté de ça toutes les
difficultés que c'est con qu'on
rencontre mais pour lesquelles j'espère
que l'action politique va apporter un
des vrais résultats
merci nadia les d'avoir participé à ce
café politique je rappelle que vous êtes
seul un député et les rues même de la
11e circonscription des yvelines
prochain numéro du café politique
vendredi soir prochain 20h30
[Musique]
et